si ustedes se enfrentan cara a cara con
un sofisticado problema de la segunda
ley de newton van a necesitar una
comprensión sofisticada de esta segunda
ley de newton y es lo que quiero
mostrarles aquí para que no importa qué
escenario enfrenten ustedes sepan
aplicar esta ley de la forma correcta la
mayor parte de las personas conoce la
segunda ley de newton como efe y la m
por lo que está bien es una forma
sencilla de comprenderlo y es suficiente
para problemas sencillos si tengo la
masa de un asteroide por ejemplo tiene
una masa m y se encuentra en el espacio
por lo que no hay resistencia al aire ni
fricción y sólo tengo una fuerza en él
la fuerza efe esta fuerza va a la
derecha y digamos que es de 50 newtons
bueno sustituyo los 50 newtons en la
fuerza sustituyó la masa del asteroide
que digamos es de 10 kilogramos
y encuentro la aceleración del asteroide
en este caso 50 entre 10 nos va a dar 5
metros por segundo al cuadrado pero qué
pasa si tenemos otras fuerzas sobre este
asteroide imaginemos que hay otra fuerza
que va a la izquierda y es de 30 newtons
vamos a ponerles nombre esta de acá
vamos a ponerle f1 y la de 50 newtons
que es la magnitud de esta fuerza y f2
tiene una magnitud de 30 newtons apunta
a la izquierda por lo que si es una
dirección negativa pero digamos que
estas fuerzas sólo están mostrando la
magnitud la dirección la vamos a tener
indicada por el sentido de las flechas
ahora que podemos hacer bueno para
resolverlo tenemos que comprender que
este lado de la izquierda no es sólo una
fuerza es la fuerza neta o también lo
pueden llamar la suma de las fuerzas
para denotar la fuerza neta muchas veces
usamos esta letra griega que es sigma y
sigma es un símbolo matemático que
representa las
de lo que sea que esté a continuación
así que esto es la suma de las fuerzas
que es lo que está a continuación de
este símbolo si tuviera una g sería la
suma de las g
si tuviera h sería la suma de las haches
es la suma de todas las fuerzas en este
caso y eso sería igual a la masa por la
aceleración en este caso tomamos los 50
newtons que son positivos porque van a
la derecha y yo podría elegir que hacia
la derecha sea negativo pero la
convención lo que más se usa es que las
direcciones a la derecha sean positivas
igual las direcciones hacia arriba
también son positivas por lo que si
estos son 50 minutos a la derecha van a
ser 50 newtons positivos y aquí aunque
tengo que sumar las fuerzas tengo que
respetar el sentido o el signo que
tienen tengo que sumarlas como vectores
esta fuerza de aquí es un vector
esta es una ecuación de vectores la
aceleración también es un vector no
puedo sumar directamente 50 más 30
porque los vectores que apuntan hacia la
izquierda se van a considerar negativos
y los que apuntan a la derecha son
positivos por lo que tenemos 50 newtons
menos 30 newtons y esto va a ser igual a
la masa por la aceleración por lo que
y poner aquí los 10 kilogramos
directamente si quiero la multiplicó por
an y en este caso me queda 20 newtons
entre 10 es 2 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
tenemos que sumar estos como vectores y
si llegara a tener más fuerzas aquí
simplemente las voy a sumar como
vectores si tuviera otra fuerza acá que
a lo mejor es de 25 newtons la llamamos
f 3 y digamos que tengo otra fuerza
hacia la izquierda f 4 que es de 40
minutos 40 newtons a la izquierda que es
f 4 y puedo seguir agregando fuerzas
aquí y los voy a sumar como vectores los
40 newtons apuntan hacia la izquierda
por lo que van a ser negativos aquí
pongo menos 40 newtons y estos 25
apuntan a la derecha por lo que van a
ser positivos más 25 newtons así
encuentro mi fuerza neta la suma de
todas mis fuerzas y esto me permitirá
encontrar la aceleración
y hay un problema muchas veces muchas
veces a los físicos no les gusta
escribir esto con esta anotación al
menos los físicos que están interesados
en la educación no les gusta esta forma
de la segunda ley de newton y la razón
es que muchos estudiantes tienen ideas
erróneas con esto piensan que conforme
van dibujando las fuerzas aquí m por ahí
también va a ser una fuerza quieren
dibujar una fuerza extra en este
asteroide que quizá apunte a la derecha
y que sea m por a
pero la masa por la aceleración no es
una fuerza masa por la aceleración es a
lo que la fuerza es igual nada más si
calculamos la fuerza neta en un objeto
que es la suma de todas las fuerzas en
él resulta que eso será igual a mejorar
pero m ahora no es una fuerza por lo que
no podemos dibujar esto como una fuerza
aquí así que no lo hagan no la dibujen
como una fuerza pues m por a sólo es lo
que resulta d
son más todas las fuerzas involucradas
así que como esto causa confusión vamos
a reescribir la segunda ley de newton de
otra manera que es igual de válida en
términos algebraicos pero ayuda a evitar
que las personas caigan en esta idea
errónea esta otra forma de expresar la
segunda ley de newton es que la
aceleración es igual a la fuerza neta
entre la masa y pueden decirme bueno
pues qué novedoso nada más estoy
dividiendo a ambos lados de la ecuación
por m a quién le importa bueno esto es
mejor porque es más difícil que las
personas confundan la aceleración con
una fuerza si la expresamos así es más
difícil que las personas diga nada y la
aceleración también es una fuerza puede
ocurrir pero es más difícil recordemos
que la aceleración no es una fuerza es
un vector y no es un vector de fuerza y
otra cosa por la que es buena esta
anotación es que nos muestra la relación
que hay en la aceleración entre la
fuerza neta y la masa la fuerza neta es
lo que nos va a dar la aceleración
mayor fuerza neta tengamos más grande
será la aceleración así que nos muestra
que la aceleración es proporcional a la
fuerza neta a la suma de las fuerzas y
nos muestra que la aceleración es
inversamente proporcional a la masa del
objeto mientras más grande sea la masa
menor será la aceleración y esa es otra
razón por la que esta anotación es buena
nos muestra de qué depende la
aceleración en términos de la fuerza
neta y la masa aquí hay otro problema
aunque esta anotación es mejor podemos
escribirla así y evitar caer en ideas
errores aquí el problema es qué pasa si
agregó otra fuerza
digamos que estoy agregando una fuerza
que va hacia abajo y digamos que esta
fuerza es de 28 newtons y esto es f 5 y
bueno tenemos estos 28 newtons hacia
abajo y ustedes pueden decir bueno pues
voy a sumarlo a las otras fuerzas que
están y a lo mejor quisieran escribir
este 28 directo aquí como un -28 ya que
va hacia abajo resulta que esto no lo
podemos hacer y la razón es que de la
misma forma que no pudimos sumar 50 más
30 porque estamos sumando los como
vectores el que va a la izquierda es
negativo y el que va a la derecha es
positivo no podemos tomar una fuerza
vertical y sumar o restar t la magnitud
de aquellas fuerzas horizontales si
sumamos fuerzas horizontales y fuerzas
verticales no nos va a dar la fuerza
neta piensa 1 de esta manera si tenemos
cierta fuerza que va a la derecha y
cierta fuerza que va hacia arriba
de estas dos no va a ser igual a la
magnitud de esta más la magnitud de esta
otra tenemos que sumarlas usando el
teorema de pitágoras si sumamos los
vectores vamos a obtener este vector
como resultado el vector resultante lo
vamos a encontrar con al cuadrado más b
al cuadrado igual ac al cuadrado y
ustedes me pueden decir ahí sabes que yo
no quiero hacer trigonometría y resulta
que no la tienen que hacer al menos a
uno si estas son las únicas fuerzas que
tenemos no tenemos por qué usar
trigonometría solamente estoy
mostrándoles con esto que no pueden
sumar directamente un vector que va a la
izquierda con otro vector que va hacia
abajo pero lo que pueden hacer es tomar
las fuerzas horizontales trabajar con
ella sea la dirección horizontal y
aparte trabajar aquellas fuerzas
verticales con la segunda ley de newton
en la dirección vertical
un truco que siempre jugamos aquí los
físicos vamos a dividir y conquistar
tomamos todas las fuerzas horizontales y
las ponemos en su propia ecuación ya que
las fuerzas horizontales solamente van a
afectar la aceleración horizontal y si
solamente quiero la aceleración
horizontal tomo solamente las fuerzas
horizontales la suma como vectores y
obtengo mi aceleración horizontal o tomo
solamente las fuerzas en dirección
vertical las 1 como vectores y obtengo
la aceleración vertical por lo que voy a
hacer una ecuación para cada dirección
de manera independiente y así sé que
puedo obtener cada componente de la
aceleración al usar las fuerzas en esa
dirección en particular este es un buen
truco usar una ecuación para cada
dirección de manera independiente y
digamos que quiero mi vector de
aceleración total hablamos de fuerzas
todos los vectores se sumen de la misma
manera si encontramos la aceleración
total en la dirección horizontal y la
aceleración total en la dirección
vertical podremos encontrar la magnitud
de nuestro vector aceleración total
nuevamente usando el teorema de
pitágoras y esa es una forma bastante
práctica de trabajar con estas fuerzas
vamos a agregar otra fuerza aquí
simplemente pues para tener otra fuerza
en la dirección vertical si tengo aquí
está
efe 6 que es de 42 newtons hacia arriba
como la vamos a incluir bueno ya
trabajamos con la dirección en x que fue
esta que tienen todas las fuerzas en la
dirección x cuya suma es igual a la masa
por la aceleración en la dirección
horizontal esta es la fórmula que usamos
para encontrar la aceleración en
dirección horizontal con la suma de
todas las fuerzas en esta dirección
tomamos todas estas fuerzas la
sustituimos aquí en la fuerza neta en
esta fórmula
lo dividimos entre la masa y encontramos
la aceleración en la dirección x para la
dirección vertical podemos decir que la
aceleración en i será la fuerza neta en
la dirección y aquí sólo vamos a tomar
en cuenta las fuerzas verticales tengo
efe 6 que es de 42 newtons que va hacia
arriba por lo que es positivo y le
restamos 28 lo restamos porque 28 va en
la dirección hacia abajo y por
convención todo lo que apunta hacia
abajo es negativo
ahora dividimos esto entre la masa 10
kilogramos y nos da la aceleración en la
dirección vertical ahora que ya tenemos
estas dos podemos calcular si queremos a
x cuadrada más cuadrada nos va a dar el
cuadrado de la magnitud de la
aceleración total vamos a hacer esto un
poquito más difícil para ver que también
dominamos esto vamos a hacer un poco de
espacio aquí seguimos aplicando estos 40
newtons pero lo pongo aquí para que me
deje espacio y digamos que hay un
por adicional involucrado aquí este
vector apunta hacia acá y la magnitud de
este vector que le llamamos efe 745
newtons 45 minutos aplicados con un
ángulo digamos que de 30 grados como
trabajamos con esto es un problema más
sofisticado de la segunda ley de newton
muchas personas que no saben cómo
trabajar con esto tratan de sumar este
vector de 45 newtons en cualquiera de
las direcciones hacia arriba o hacia
abajo
quizás digan que van en la dirección
horizontal porque apunta hacia la
izquierda y otros quizás quieran
agregarlo en la dirección vertical
porque también apunta hacia arriba y
muchas personas suman toda esta magnitud
en la dirección vertical pero esto no se
puede hacer ya que solo las fuerzas
verticales o los componentes verticales
de una fuerza que miren esta ecuación
vertical y sólo las fuerzas horizontales
o los componentes horizontales de una
fuerza pueden ir en esta ecuación
horizontal
y yo creo que ustedes ya saben que
tenemos que hacer tenemos que
descomponer esta fuerza en sus
componentes horizontal y vertical
tenemos que encontrar de esta fuerza
total de 45 newtons cuánto de esta
fuerza se aplica hacia la izquierda y
cuánto de esta fuerza se aplica hacia
arriba por lo que tenemos que encontrar
cuál es el componente horizontal
cuál es el componente que va en la
dirección vertical
efe 7 en la dirección
estoy aquí abajo es efe 7 en la
dirección x
tenemos que encontrar cuáles son estos
componentes y una vez que los
encontremos agregarlos a la ecuación que
les corresponden efe 7x y da en la
ecuación horizontal y f 7 que irá a la
ecuación vertical pero recuerden que no
puedo poner toda la magnitud de los 45
minutos verticales u horizontales porque
no toda este vector va hacia arriba o
hacia la izquierda solo una parte de él
y tenemos que usar trigonometría y
tomaremos este vector de 50 minutos y lo
vamos a descomponer como lo vamos a
hacer esto lo vamos a resolver con la
definición de seno y cosenos este es
nuestro vector de 45 minutos este lado
será el lado adyacente al ángulo de 30
grados este f 7 en la dirección x
efe 7 en la dirección vertical es el
lado opuesto al ángulo y ahora usamos
senos y cosenos cuál es la definición de
coseno el cose no de teta es el lado
adyacente entre la hipotenusa el lado
adyacente es este que está tocando el
ángulo que es f 7x la hipotenusa es la
magnitud total de este vector que es de
45 newtons y ahora despejó efe 7x y me
queda que es igual
45 newtons por el coseno de 30 grados y
ahora puedo tomar este valor de f-7 en
la dirección x el valor que sea ustedes
lo pueden calcular y todo este valor y
lo agrego a la ecuación de la dirección
horizontal en la suma de las fuerzas lo
pongo aquí como positivo o negativo
efe 7 y apunta hacia arriba este sería
positivo pero
7x apunta hacia la izquierda es negativo
nos interesa la dirección horizontal la
dirección vertical aquí no la estamos
tomando en cuenta por lo que este
componente como apunta hacia la
izquierda lo tenemos que escribir como
negativo menos 45 newtons por el coseno
de 30 grados para la dirección en que
usamos la definición del seno el seno
del ángulo teta es igual a el lado
opuesto que en este caso es f 7 y el
opuesto al ángulo el seno es el opuesto
entre la hipotenusa el opuesto es f 7 en
la dirección james dividido entre la
hipotenusa que es la magnitud de todo
este vector 45 newtons por lo que f 7 en
la dirección lleva a ser igual a 45
newtons por el seno de 30 grados y ahora
todo esto que es el componente vertical
y lo agrego a la suma de las fuerzas en
la ecuación vertical
será positivo o negativo bueno el
componente vertical va hacia arriba por
lo que va a ser positivo más 45 newtons
por el seno de 30 grados vaya ahora si
ya estamos completamente preparados para
aplicar la segunda ley de newton quizás
estas fuerzas no son fuerzas de un
asteroide a lo mejor son de tensión o de
gravedad o fuerzas normales fuerzas de
fricción quizás son fuerzas en cualquier
dirección
pero estas reglas siguen aplicando sin
importar cuál sea la fuerza si va hacia
arriba si va hacia abajo si va a la
izquierda va a la derecha o en diagonal
ahora ya saben cómo usar la segunda ley
de newton sin importar la dirección de
las fuerzas